there are too many families who came
here to give birth but left grieving the
death of their baby mistakes have been
made and repeated now the police will
investigate whether the trust or any of
its staff should face criminal charges
ready Isabella Stanton Davis should have
an older sister Richard and Rhiannon's
first daughter but Kate only lived for a
few hours this was the first and last
time Rhiannon was able to hold her we
didn't know what's going on I'd never
held a newborn baby before I seemed
everything was normal you know Kate
didn't want to feed or anything bad and
I never saw Kate alive again I was shown
Kate in a side room and told that the
situation was really poor and I cradled
Kate while she died in my arms just six
hours after hear Rihanna had given birth
to her so this is her but Kate should be
11 now in the years since her death her
family have written cards and wrapped
presents for every birthday and
Christmas they've also learned her death
could have been avoided if doctors and
midwives had recognized she was
seriously ill before it was too late
since Kate died her parents have fought
to uncover failings at the trust with
hundreds of cases now being investigated
they welcomed the involvement of the
police where one death is avoidable it's
avoidable that's that's criminal that is
criminal to have hundreds and hundreds
where the learning has not been taken
forward there's no question has never
been a question in my mind the assistant
Chief Constable of West Mercia Police
said we can confirm that a police
investigation will be conducted to
explore whether there is evidence to
support a criminal case either against
the trust or any individuals involved an
independent midwife led investigation is
already underway in April 2017 then
Health Secretary Jeremy Hunt announced
the investigation into a cluster of a
double baby deaths at the trust it
initially focused on 23 cases where
failings were alleged by August 2018 at
least 60 separate cases were being
looked at including deaths of babies and
mothers as well as babies left with
permanent brain damage since then
hundreds more families have come forward
the investigation is now looking at more
than 1,200 cases from between 1979 and
the present day it's already being
described as the worst maternity scandal
in the history of the NHS the
involvement now of the police is
undoubtedly a major development and an
indicator of how serious the failings
have been here the Trust's chief
executive has confirmed they will
cooperate fully with the police
investigation for too many families
there will always be someone missing a
legacy of poor care that may now lead to
criminal charges Becky Johnson Sky News